انتقل مباشرة إلى الجانب العلمي من
هذا
وما كنت تكتبه وتتحدث
عنه
خاصة الآن في موقف
مثل هذا قد
يكون مغيرًا رئيسيًا للعبة ومحسنًا
لمقاومة الناس الجسدية أخبرني عن ذلك
نعم لذلك هناك الكثير  الارتباط الوثيق
بين صحة نومك
وصحتك المناعية ، وسأعطيك فقط
ثلاثة أمثلة ذات صلة بالسياق
الذي نجد أنفسنا فيه الآن
أولًا نعلم أن الأفراد الذين
ينامون أقل من سبع
ساعات هم أكثر عرضة
للإصابة بالعدوى بثلاث مرات.  فيروسات الأنف
أو البرد الشائع
الثاني نعلم أن الأفراد الذين
ينامون خمس ساعات
أو أقل في الليلة هم في الواقع أكثر عرضة بنسبة 70 في المائة
للإصابة بالالتهاب الرئوي
وهو عنصر حاسم في
معادلة الطمع
وأخيراً ما نعرفه هو أنك إذا
لم تحصل على  الحصول على قسط كافٍ من النوم
في الأسبوع
الذي يسبق حصولك على لقاح الإنفلونزا ، أنت
تنتج فقط خمسين بالمائة أو أقل من خمسين
بالمائة
من الجسم المضاد الطبيعي.
لذلك ، يجعل هذا التطعيم
أقل فعالية بشكل ملحوظ ، لذا
أعتقد أن ما يخبرنا به هذا أولاً هو
أن
النوم سيعيد تزويد الأسلحة في
ترسانتك المناعية ونعلم كيف يحفز
النوم هذا في
الواقع إنتاج
العوامل المناعية ولكنه أيضًا يحسس
جسمك
تجاه هؤلاء.  الاستجابات المناعية ، لذلك عندما
تستيقظ في صباح اليوم التالي ،
فأنت شخص أكثر قوة مناعة ،
لذا يمكنك التفكير في النوم
تقريبًا مثل أفضل بوليصة تأمين صحي
في هذا الصدد ، ولكن بعد ذلك
أعتقد أنك ذكرتها فقط في
la ، نعم يمكنك أن تأتي
تمسك بهذه الفكرة ،
أريد فقط أن أسألك وألتقط
ما قلته عن اللقاح ، إذا
لم تحصل على قسط جيد من النوم ، أعتقد أنك
قلت قبل خمسة أيام من
إنفلونزا البرد أو بالأحرى لقاح الإنفلونزا ، فمن
غير المحتمل  للعمل بشكل فعال ،
هل يمكنك نقل ذلك إلى
لقاح covid متى وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ،
فهذا هو بالضبط ما كنت
سأقوم بربطه بك ، أعلم أنك
ذكرتني  في الجزء الأخير الذي
ربما يكون الصيف أو بعيدًا ،
لكن سيكون لدينا لقاح أو عدة
لقاحات لفيروس كورونا
في المستقبل ، السؤال الحاسم
للعلماء مثلي
هو أننا نحتاج بعد ذلك إلى الدراسة هل
هناك نفس العلاقة بين
النوم  وتحصينك السري الناجح
لأنه إذا كان هناك ، فقد يكون ذلك أيضًا
مجرد تغيير لقواعد اللعبة كما ذكرت ،
هل يمكننا تتبع نوم الأشخاص ، هل يمكننا
تقديره ونقول إنني أعلم أن لديك
موعدًا قادمًا هذا الأسبوع
يبدو كما لو أن نومك  لم
تكن هناك تمامًا حتى الآن ،
دعني أقدم لك ثلاثة خيارات للأسبوع المقبل
، فلنحاول تصحيح
نومك وبهذه الطريقة لا نهدر أولاً
توزيع اللقاح المغطى الحرج
وثانيًا نحاول
زيادة احتمالية نجاحك
ستكون بصحة جيدة خلال
هجمات الطمع اللاحقة